Oh
what has been true to too great an
extent in conventional medicine in this
country and I think in a lot of places
is that death is seen as the ultimate
failure you know against which you fight
with big guns all the way to the end and
we see that for a lot of people that's
not appropriate I mean I don't know what
the experience was with the author's
friend but for many people it it becomes
appropriate at a certain point that is I
think most appropriately determined by
that person themselves or in conjunction
with their loved ones and under the
advisement of the medical profession you
know when to make the transition away
from the aggressive interventions and
and go more for quality of life dignity
you know having a peaceful death but I
think a really important point is that
that line is different for every person
there was just an article on the front
page of the New York Times the other day
about a patient who was at Mount Sinai
Anwar and was one of the patients of one
of our palliative medicine doctors and
and the patient herself was a palliative
medicine doctor that was what was so
interesting and she herself although she
had been involved in the field of
helping people you know make that
transition she herself found that she
had to fight she had to keep fighting
for herself she continued to pursue
aggressive therapy up pretty close to
the end and and so the important point
was that that was her individual
decision and so what what some people
might have taken away from the article
will here was a palliative medicine
doctor who wasn't doing what she
preached that really wasn't the message
it was the message that for every person
you know they should be empowered to
make the right choices based on their
personal preferences but they should you
know I think it's I think it's the role
of people who are interested in seeing
the the experian
dying change to a much you know better
death I mean that's that's a question is
there such a thing as a good death and I
think I think yes I've seen good deaths
and I think there can be much better
deaths for a lot of people so you know
we have a long way to go even relieving
relieving pain and suffering we don't do
a good job of that so this woman's
friend you know she may not have had a
an adequate might not have had adequate
treatment of her pain as as the the
medical profession we frequently fail in
that regard so you know we really need
to improve people's knowledge about an
ability to relieve pain and that would
change the face of dying as well you
know I think a lot of patience and
there's great interest in in assisted
suicide and that's a whole you know a
whole big area of discussion but it
would probably be true that for a lot of
patients who were interested in assisted
suicide you know maybe the point of that
decision would change if they had better
treatment you know if they were more
comfortable with with the process that
they were going through